foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
got a wild rowdy crowd All My Rowdy
Friends the only normal people in all of
New York City are in this room tonight
thank you for being with us thank you at
home for being with us and by the way
tonight the uh Joe Biden bribery and
money laundering allegation Scandal that
is heating up in big and major ways soon
the medium mob that has been protecting
uh Joe who doesn't know it's Thursday uh
they will have to even cover this story
look one FBI expert is now saying that
evidence is sufficient for a real
Federal probe into bribery and money
laundering into the Biden family and
that means the big guy himself Joe Biden
and this was on just thenews.com
breaking about a half hour ago coming up
tonight Senator Ted Cruz former acting
attorney general Matt Whitaker and our
very own Greg Jarrett will be here they
will break down the law how much trouble
are they really in let's jump right into
what we are calling the evolution
solution tonight of the Biden lie now
first Biden and his staff is remember
they all swore Joe said it as president
he said it as candidate that never once
ever did he ever speak or or or talk to
Hunter or uh his brother Joe or anybody
for that matter about his farm business
dealings he never discussed these
foreign deals with any of these people
ever then the story changed then they
said Joe Biden was never in business
with hunter or his brother or any of
these foreign business partners and that
has evolved into an admission well Joe
Biden met with Hunter's business
partners some of them or talk to others
two dozen of them on the phone but he
didn't discuss business over what uh a
dozen conversations two dozen
conversation and when Joe did get on the
phone when he did go to dinner with them
at Cafe Milano
um all they talked about was the weather
that's what they're telling you now the
latest Democratic party and media mob
spin is a concession okay uh the big guy
did have some kind of role in Hunter's
business deals uh but as one former
White House deputy director proudly
quoted well the coma memo does not show
direct payment to Joe Biden they need to
read the foreign corruption act and and
the federal laws because you see he
doesn't have to benefit if he takes
actions as that 1023 form said as vice
president that directly benefit and
enrich his family that's bribery
according to the law Greg Jarrett will
explain see the foreign money went to
Hunter and other Biden family members
first and we all just need to move along
that's what they're telling us well who
Among Us has not had foreign adversaries
send cash to our family members even our
grandchildren
through none of that has happened to you
I can't believe through shell
corporations often from America's Top
geopolitical foes and for no apparent
reason while they are addicted to crack
cocaine and hookers and having no
experience in the areas which with they
are working now as you all know Hunter
was the admitted crack addict during
most if not all of those transactions at
one point is drug use was so bad look at
that that he was practically toothless
that happens to crack addicts the teeth
right out right out of their head anyway
so we're supposed to believe that unlike
most addicts Hunter was a highly
functioning crack addict
that he actually earned the tens of
millions of dollars without any
experience an energy oil gas Ukraine
China Russia Ukraine and none of this uh
now remember Hunter is also reportedly
very stupid
well I didn't say it if you look at the
1023 form it cites the head of barisma
that's the oil and gas giant in Ukraine
calling Hunter dumb and stupid and the
guy even went as far as to say that he
thought his dog was smarter than Hunter
now to be very blunt the Apple doesn't
fall very far from the tree
so
so many
rich
successful foreigners paying Hunter and
his friends and family all of these tens
of millions of dollars just to be nice I
don't know in order to better answer the
question tonight let's meet some of some
of Hunter's most generous Partners
according to last night's bank Memo from
the house oversight committee quote in
February 2014 a Russian oligarch sent
3.5 million to a shell company
associated with Hunter Biden and Devin
Archer the Russian oligarch her name is
Elena batarina she's pictured here with
a woman brace with Vladimir Putin she
was married to the late mayor of Moscow
and that mayor had deep ties to Vladimir
Putin a few months after sending uh the
3.5 million dollars to Hunter well she
then enjoyed a lovely dinner at Cafe
Milano with Hunter and then Vice
President Joe Biden and Devin Archer
said she invested a whopping 120 million
dollars in the company's real estate
division let's go on to the next country
up next we have a prominent member of
the Chinese Communist party that is our
number one geopolitical foe
yichi aming is the name quote the
committee is identified over 8 million
dollars that benefited the Biden family
and Associates from this and related
Chinese sources now Yi Chang aming uh by
the way was arrested in 2018 by Chinese
authorities get this can you believe it
what what luck for bribery and coming up
next let's go to Kazakhstan shall we uh
there's Kazakh business partners on the
left is Kenneth rakashev and on the
right former prime minister Kareem
massimov now in the middle you can see
Joe and Hunter they're grinning year to
year why wouldn't they be there was also
reportedly a lunch a dinner at Cafe
Milano two months later these well
businessmen reportedly wired Hunter
money to buy a beautiful sports car the
exact amount amount of money for Hunter
Biden's brand new beautiful expensive
Porsche now one of the individuals
that's massimov was recently sentenced
to 18 years in prison for treason and
abuse of power shocking now let's take a
look at Hunter's Romanian partner quote
Gabriel Popovich papavicha and by the
way the committee has identified three
million that benefited the Biden family
and Associates from the Romanian Source
this individual has been convicted of
bribery and abuse of power in Romania
um is anybody seeing a trend here which
brings us to Ukraine and barisma which
was facing a corruption investigation
until the big guy stepped in and he's
the one that leveraged one billion of
your tax dollars to get that guy fired
that prosecutor fired who was
investigating Hunter and barisma and he
did it within six hours son of a bee
they did it and guess who continue to
get paid and continue to have enrichment
that would be Hunter based on the
actions of his vice president Daddy and
breaking tonight a photograph has now
emerged showing then Vice President
Biden on Air Force 2 on the way to
Ukraine with a hunter Biden linked
associate in 2015. this was right before
Joe got that prosecutor fired at the
very same time Hunter was making
millions of dollars from barisma and
again he was a crack addict at the time
uh Venom uh pazarsky was the Chief
Financial Officer of barisma and
allegedly told an FBI informant that he
put Hunter on the board to protect us
through his dad now you look at him
Nikola zolacewski was the head of
barisma he allegedly told the same FBI
informant about his dog being smarter
than Hunter that's the guy right there
he was forced to pay a 5 million dollar
bribe to Hunter another five million
dollar bribe to Joe he said he didn't
want to do it he said he did it for
protection and he also said and added it
would take 10 years for people to be
able to trace how that payment was made
and oddly enough according to the
Federalists a notable 8.7 million dollar
Gap does exist between Joe and Jill
Biden's 9.5 million dollar net income in
the year 2017 and the 809 uh thousand
seven hundred nine dollar oz of
disclosed income in that Year from the
book tour and related speaking events
guess what we still don't know where
that 8.7 million dollars came from the
bidens filed their income tax through an
S corp they refused to release that form
publicly I thought they were going to be
transparent but according to Biden's
water boy over at the liberal Washington
Post Phillip pump
what a name bump
he's got a bump in his head anyway
there's just nothing to see here and
nothing to the investigation nothing to
report on meanwhile the fake Washington
Post fact Checker Glenn Kessler needs to
be fact checked and he keeps quietly
updating his bogus reporting about the
Biden family business without ever
issuing a correction the fact Checker
needs to be fact checked and the last
night by the way all three networks
completely ignored the house oversight
committee and James Comer's latest
report but on fake news CNN fake Jake
Tapper he was able to muster a little
feigned outrage in this question to
Elizabeth Warren take a look
people close to Joe Biden or people
close to Donald Trump but I'm talking
about Joe Biden making tens of millions
of dollars because of their closeness to
him that can't be something that you
like that can't be something that you're
comfortable with
um as a phenomenon
look I I always worry about the
influence Peddlers in Washington
regardless of party affiliation one of
the things as you know I've spent a lot
of my time in Congress working on is how
we bring just more ethics and more
oversight in general
I see a lot of passion there a real real
real commitment to get to the bottom of
this she just loves oversight and
accountability
but is making no effort to investigate
Biden and his family and The Syndicate
that it now is so where do we go from
here how do we hold Biden accountable
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else